[Musique]
eh bien nous avons ici une quarantaine
de salles de classe pour 500 élèves
parfaitement autonome à qui nous
assureront simplement connaissance et
soutien bah c'est une super école
l'ambiance y est vraiment agréable les
profs super sous moi si j'ai intégré la
échapper c'est avant tout pour pratiquer
mon tour et de professionnels développer
mes acquis mois sport basé de la meuf
plein alors moi c'est mon père qui a
voulu que je suis ce cursus
eh bien je dirais qu'aujourd'hui la
femme c'est la meilleure école pour
étudier la pornographie de l'érotisme
soft autres à charcot au nom non [ __ ]
ont donc des deux matelas tabata tous
les jeux la messe à 15 heures pour le
compte d'autrui cool d'un pote robert
toi je vous dérange pas j'espère au
moins que voilà qu on qu'on préférerait
c'est peut-être parce que je suis un
plan cérébral mais définitivement les
cours d'eau scénario vous surprendre moi
je suis de cours pratiques
oui c'est notre spécificité d'offrir en
plus des cours théoriques des cours
purement pratiques pour mieux
appréhender le milieu du travail après
les études bon les filles vous attachez
vos cheveux et vous mettez vos lunettes
s'il ya des 2e année oublier les
lunettes si je devais dire un dernier
mot
et bien simplement que nos inscriptions
commencent le mois prochain et nous
sommes impatients vous voir la femme et
surtout ne vous inquiétez pas ici ce
n'est pas la taille qui compte c'est le
diplôme la femme jamais faire du ana
étaient aussi visés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]